hi guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to some
more kevin samuels
in my last video i made a comment
that women don't necessarily need a man
in 2021 which i think you guys took out
of context but i'm gonna explain that
opinion
later in the video um the title of the
video is we need to
teach women to not need men so i'm gonna
see
what opinions of kevin samuels i agreed
with
and which ones i disagree with so let me
know in the comments
like which video i should do next and
let me know if you think i got it right
or if i got it wrong
and don't forget to subscribe don't
forget
do not forget okay let me switch it to
scene two
all right
i always like his music like i feel very
um but i feel as though the nurturing
and the procreation
piece in part is not necessarily a
luxury
um i think that it's dangerous hold on
hold on hold on hold on hold on
i didn't say it was a luxury the
conversation is do
we need each other for survival
right and so just to clarify
as a species yes like i would say like
as a civilization women and men need
each other
duh as far as survival i think that if
you know men did not have women um you
guys would
survive a lot longer on this planet
without
women than women would be able to
survive without men
however there do there does come a time
where men begin to die out
that's not the point i get that
that's i mean it's it's like you guys
want to make this point because it's the
only point to make
granted we're not talking about
reproduction
women if men were gone women could not
even live to the end of their natural
lives
men could land to the end of their
natural lives even if we couldn't
reproduce
and so i think that the the conversation
is around
two extremes to make a very very
important point
because i do feel as though a lot of
women do not
see the need for men and do not respect
men for what they bring to the table
however i think that saying
to men especially men who are not as
cognizant as yourself
it doesn't matter she's just talking in
circles like i have no idea what she's
saying
okay look
they don't have to be the men who are
already doing the jobs would stay
doing the jobs
they don't have to become they don't
have to become cognizant of the bank
they we just need a certain amount of
replacements for the men who die off
that are doing the jobs
man a certain amount of replacements for
them because we would take and we
okay and we okay ma'am
i get it you want to make the
reproduction argument that's not part of
this conversation
we're not reproducing all human beings
are now sterile
i'm thanos right i can snap women away i
can snap me in a way i'm gonna
i hate to say this this is cut this is a
dumb argument
that's never gonna happen obviously men
and women need each other but
snap away reproduction we're all sterile
now okay
so even if you existed we still couldn't
reproduce now
let's go from there do sterile men
need sterile women to survive
no no sterile women need sterile men to
survive
more more of them would yes i do agree
with that
i guess i think that my my concern about
this type of argument is that do men
then begin to see the value in teaching
women how to survive
or don't they look at women no no no no
no no no no no
see that's the misunderstanding that we
need to teach you guys how to do
anything
it's your responsibility to learn you
wanted freedom
no no no you wanted freedom you wanted
equality now it's your responsibility
women are free to go into science
engineering technology and math
women are free to go into all of these
professions
no one's stopping women and women choose
not to go into them because you don't
want to
women don't want to do the jobs
so women now and i and i and i believe
too
that we are like saying or referring to
modern women
and so modern women have been
conditioned in a certain way and i think
that that's there we go with that
[ __ ] is not a child's fault now
no i'm not saying that it's not our
fault i think that we do definitely have
to take responsibility
however i think that bringing up the
argument okay we as men don't need you
guys
doesn't shed light on what women need to
learn or ignore whose responsibility
okay
and who okay let me explain let me ask
you a question here
if i'm in the position where i can live
without you
and you're in a position where you can't
live without me
who needs to learn what who needs to who
needs to act with a sense of urgency in
that situation
i think the women do and stop stop right
stop right there
okay stop right there women need to act
with a sense of urgency because without
us you die
women are not only not acting with a
sense of urgency you're walking around
talking about you don't need men
they're going the opposite direction so
saying that i think it's a destructive
conversation or we need to do something
men are saying we're tired of holding
your hand you want freedom you want to
be away from us you want to call
everything that we do
toxic and misogynist or whatever fine
we'll go over here and do what we do
we'll be just fine and then when you
finally realize you the women who follow
you are smart enough to realize
that your life is better with us than
without us and you wanted to get on our
page
we'll work with you the ones that don't
okay i agree like honestly um
what i was saying is that like
if you make smart financial decisions as
a woman and you work hard you can be put
in a position
where you don't need a man to
financially support you
and there is a benefit to that because
you can really like
marry someone that you have fun with or
you really
just enjoy their company um and i just
say that because
like i don't know like there's a benefit
to that
but like do i think society could live
without men
no no i don't do i think women
need men to survive outside of fertility
i do i do as like a group but like there
are some women that
really don't and it's really tough
because he's talking to individuals but
he's using group
arguments and that's where sometimes i
see like a disconnect because
you're saying like okay society needs
this society like
take me for example right i come from a
wealthy
household i don't necessarily need to
marry a guy for money
i don't necessarily need to marry a guy
like making six figures so
you know whatever like
i mean i can like i mean don't
don't don't go in the comments and say
no you can't do
it or not kevin samuels fans are like
crazy sometimes
but you know what i'm saying though like
it all just depends on the like what the
woman situation is some women are like
very independent
and they just want to do their career
make a lot of money
and live alone i wouldn't recommend it i
wouldn't choose that lifestyle but some
girls can
and so i guess the women who are not
getting on the page
so i i definitely feel as though yes
women need to get on the page because
like you said
men do have the knowledge that rather
now men have more of the knowledge
because of how women
you know think about as of now it's not
as of now
as of now meaning what the women
couldn't do it before
they were kept from the knowledge not
saying that they were kept from and i do
not i think that women did
you know develop these ideas and they
turned away from it i do agree that and
i
and i can take responsibility for that i
myself
do see the value in having a man however
my
my concern though is that because women
have had this perception for so long
now you have men and women both bitter
against each other until
no no no no no no no
men you have women bitter against men
okay where are the men walking around
talking about scrubs and ain't nothing
going on but the rent
you got women who don't oh don't no no
no you got me in responding
to those songs you don't have men making
those songs
while scrubs was coming out you had baby
face in mint conditions talking about
pretty brown eyes
and joe all the things your man won't do
see this is what we need to have a come
to jesus moment the problem is not with
the men
the problem is with women's opinion of
men
you women in the west are out of step
with reality
and nature has a way of correcting it
see funny thing is nature has a sense of
humor
scrubs and independent and all this
other stuff we don't need them in and
the future is female and abort male
babies and all this other stuff and all
these other
crazy feminist notions then the world
said okay all right
cool here you go here's a little virus
for you
boom and then all those strong
independent women
were sitting around the grocery store
and the food marlin
yeah so i feel like it's almost like we
missed each other in that sense no no we
didn't miss each other men didn't miss
each other
men were like you didn't need us right
so when becky
was at home with her kids and tom was
going to the market
brendan keisha was like i saw fear in
women's eyes for the first time because
they had to go out and do it themselves
right so at one point in time the and
i think for me even too i'll speak more
so whenever i think about the
black community as far as
the nature of how women view and respect
their men has
changed drastically did you hear the
previous one
did you hear the woman who wouldn't even
admit
did you hear the previous caller i did i
did and i mean these and i and i can't
even
say like certain things that were said
about survival or things that i know
about survival i have learned from a man
i have and so i i just think my concern
more so is that whenever we are saying
oh
man like the for instance all of the
women callers
they are very hostile and i feel like
they're hostile because
what they hear first is we don't need
you and it's expected and
hold on what do you think many what do
you think men have been here
i'm sorry i
this is true i'm telling you guys i had
a come to like realization
moment a couple years ago where
i did not like men i thought remember
trash and i would say stuff like that
all the time
and then i had to like come inside of me
you know like come and just like think
about it
and think i have brothers that i like
they're pretty nice guys they don't
they're not mean like they don't cheat
they don't like do bad things
my dad's a great guy i like him
so if you're in a position
where you really hate men
look inside think about why do you hate
men
you know and if you get into a bad
situation once with a guy that's not
your fault
totally understand but if you
continually pick bad men like
you start to become the common
denominator
i'm sorry if they're little hostile
because one man finally shows the
numbers and puts an argument in front
and says no the truth is
we don't need you look ladies if
you're hostile and don't like it your
gender
picked the fight over my lifetime i'm
just sitting back
saying well look if this is the truth
men can survive to the end of their
natural days
can you and this woman sat here and
argued talking about she gonna drive to
the beach and boil water and [ __ ]
and then i said well can you at least
admit that you couldn't do that i i
i can you at least admit two plus two is
four that's what i asked her
at least a minute two plus two is four
uh-uh i ain't gonna do it that's why i
don't feel any sympathy for people like
that
i'm not qualified you're gonna be
willfully ignorant enjoy
and i think that's the thing so in in in
in our world now yes
i get that it's like okay am i supposed
to cuddle or do i have to step back do i
have so let me ask you let me ask you a
question before let me let me ask you a
question before i move on
soon as though you have this concern for
women and
and i and i share it and you know and
you are a different caliber woman and
you respect men
and things like that and you want to see
men and women get on the same page
that's pretty much it what i'm gathering
from you
yes that's pretty much okay so
what are you doing to help teach women
to be like you
i do have a platform that i'm attempting
to create i'm in the process
of it um so in other words
right now nothing so again no listen
listen listen listen
right now your heart's in the right
place but the actual
knowledge transfer and stuff still would
have to come from men see
i said it before and i said it again
when i talk
to uh that tawanna chick stop telling me
and what to do
i ain't doing i don't want to do another
damn thing i want you all to start doing
it
you start to listen you start checking
your
your your your sisters and you and your
woman kind
and when they coming off the mouth talk
about men ain't this net you stop many
track and say no no
we need these men we need this and that
don't duck your head don't keep on
walking
you fight back like you want the men to
fight back you do what you want the men
to do and guess what just maybe
maybe just maybe men will see an ally
and women like you and then maybe
they'll start to back you up
yeah this is something i struggle with
too because
part of b just thinks you know what if
you want to hate men that is not my
problem
i was there once and i'm not anymore but
he's right like i have brothers that's
what i always think of like
i have brothers and i have a dad and i
have like
guy friends that are really nice and i
love
and yeah i agree yeah
and so i don't i promise you i do not
bite my tongue when it when it comes to
that whether it's family whether it's
friends
i don't bite my tongue when it comes to
that when it comes to seeing females
disrespect me and even
if that man is being disrespectful in
that moment
i still will be the one to say to that
woman like
hey you got to consider it this way or
look at it this way
my only thing is that i feel as though
this is a very powerful platform and so
no i'm not telling
you as a man like oh you need to do this
and women
don't have to take any responsibility i
just feel though we both have to take
responsibility at the same
in in the same place in space because
absolutely not
absolutely not let me tell you let me
tell you why i don't believe that okay
there's a gender war
but there's a war okay there's a war
move it move it out of
there's a war between east and west
right
when the war is over
what happens there's a there's a there's
a meeting that happens
right and what happens
the winners and the losers sit down and
hammer out a what
like a compromise of some sort
what's it called
you mean like what's what called i'm
sorry it's a peace treaty
okay okay i'm with you a peace treaty
uh do the winners have to travel to the
losers home side
and sit down with them or the losers
have to go
to the winners and i guess
whenever we're looking okay sorry i'm
gonna answer your questions alright
yeah y'all going direct it is the way
yes it is that it that is the
way that it works so the winners would
not have to do the traveling
they would not have to make that
compromise no the losers have to come
down
right and sit down and compromise
and sign away everything they got to
make peace because they lost
men have never left
we didn't walk away
the black men have never haven't walked
away from the community
in this situation that woman who was
sitting there he walked away
excuse me so if
you're saying that men and women no i
don't beg to differ
no it's for women to come back
and realize that you require us on this
planet
but what i think she's trying to say is
that
there are also a lot of beta males
that is like a problem you know so like
where women need to work on one thing
like men also need to be men
and to humble yourselves of the gender
and realize that yes
we're different we have different
essences and everything else but make no
mistake the male lion can hunt by
himself
the the lionesses need the pack and they
still
can't keep what they eat hyenas will
still take from the lionesses
lionesses cannot live by themselves they
need a pride
male lions can live alone tigers can
live alone
and it's time for women to get back to a
state of nature and realize that if
there's a gender war
when a gender war is over there's a
winner and a loser and it's not for the
men to come sit down at the table first
and ask you well hey what you want
french toast that
i hate what he uses we're in a state of
nature arguments
because kevin like we're not hunting
i understand that he wants things to be
like natural and that's cool but like
there are women nowadays that are the
providers in their household it's not
the norm we definitely could not survive
without men but
like i just don't like
the hunting arguments because who cares
i don't care if a lion
can hunt by itself like i really don't
there's a winner and a loser
i want to know what's the prize then if
we're not looking in the
in the direction of men and women being
able to because even when you have a
woman who is saying okay i respect men
she's going to run into men who are not
going to believe that and see that and
are going to attack that's the question
is the winner and a loser to answer that
question no no where's a winner and a
loser finished that point
i said um as far as like there being a
winner and a loser in this context then
what's the prize
the prize is you get to continue to
exist not fortnite
well here's the the question is the
price you get to continue to exist and
you also get the chance to possibly not
die alone
that's the prize it's the prize that
every other woman on this planet ever
had
before 1965 the black community was
married at a rate of 80
the prize was you got somebody to spend
life with the prize is you didn't have
to have a damn dog
and die alone like so many women today
the prize is the prize is you get to
have an opportunity
to have a mate a partner a companion
and so i think in that sense i'm saying
if we shed light on
what the benefit is for the union
and that we don't have to share benefit
we don't have to share benefit because
ma'am see you keep trying to make us
do something men don't need to share
benefit on the union because men can get
from here
to the end of their lives without
needing you
this is what you ladies are this is
listen but in 2021
okay collectively as a group
yes women need men i'm not going to
argue that
but and i'm not someone that wants to do
this
for me don't want to do this
if i wanted to i could get a job
a high paying job save for retirement
early
start putting money away invest
diversify my assets
make enough money to live the rest of my
life
foster friendships that would make me
happy
now look i want to get married so don't
don't don't like take this out of
context but you guys get what i'm saying
i hope this is what you you still keep
trying to
somehow get men to get women
up to speed no you know what it's going
to get a woman up to speed
a woman who's been working at retail for
all of her life
and when neiman marcus finally when i
was sitting in neiman marcus when covert
hit and all those women
had to realize that neiman marcus has
filed bankruptcy
and all those stores are closing and
women who have been there since they
were 20
and they got no more skills and they're
in their 40s or 50s
what's a 40 or 50 year old unmarried
woman going to do in the world to work
and she's making 60 70 000 neiman marcus
she's gonna go back into the into the
work world with minimum wage skills
see nature just listen okay
but now there's more women going to be
doctors
than men again not a competition
like not every woman goes and works
retail like there's women
accountants there's women hello
youtubers
just you know my two cents it ain't for
men to tell
women who are independent doing their
own thing because
the world didn't tell men that they
needed to be able to take care of
themselves cover themselves provide for
themselves
because there's no safety blanket for
men there's no safety net for men
men know the world don't owe us
understanding and if we don't do it for
ourselves
you will be homeless and stepped over
women are about to start learning these
lessons
because the world is not set but those
are women that did not make
wise financial decisions you don't need
to make a lot of money
to save a lot of money if you live below
your means and you save a lot of money
like i'm pretty sure there's like a stat
that says them
like there's a good chunk like 50 of
millionaires
only made like 80k or 70k
and they just saved a lot of money their
entire life for retail
florist and people like that to live by
themselves not partner not marry not
have any children
because the state the government cannot
afford to take care of a bunch of
elderly and maturing women it cannot
and so i get and maybe this is something
that you can
help me better understand in the sense
of if
i am to go out and talk to women and
encourage them
to respect men to see the value of men
and this is something that i do it's not
on a large part
on the platform or anything like that
it's part of my how old are you i'm 20
i'm
26 i'll be 27 on uh
[Music]
i think i lost your audio
no you didn't i just stopped talking
because you were talking to me i
apologize
the best thing you can do is save
yourself
the best thing you can do is save
yourself you go find a man a black man
cooperate get on a program marry him go
make black babies
save yourself fix yourself before you
can fix the world ladies always keep
trying to save each other and you ain't
saved yourself
if you are in on an airplane what do
they tell you
when the mask drops put it over your
nose first
right yes put that [ __ ] over your nose
because you what you gonna what you
gonna say women for you don't have a man
yourself
and so this is this is what i i went in
the sense of me and this is i think
something else okay that's pretty much
the end
okay guys you know the drill let me know
in the comments am i right am i wrong
what comments
do you agree with what do you disagree
with and don't forget to like comment
and subscribe i'll talk to you guys next
time